you've spoken about Francisco de aralana
uh who's this Explorer in the in 1541
and 42 that still the length of the
Amazon probably one of the first and
that's just a few things
I should probably read uh I should
probably find a good book on him because
the guy seems like a gangster yes um
some great books on him so he sailed uh
he led the expedition that sailed all
the way for one end to the other
there's like a rebuilding of a ship
which is insanity yeah yeah see because
it speaks to the thing it's like
nobody's gonna come and rescue you no
you have to if your boat dies you gotta
have to rebuild it yeah so they came
down the Andes entered in the headwaters
of the Amazon constructed some sort of
raft boat craft something and made it
down the entire Amazon base and of
course his stories are the ones that led
to the Amazon being called the Amazon
because he reported tribes of women he
reported these large cities places where
the tribes lived on farms of river
turtles that they corralled and they
lived off of that protein and then when
they came out to the mouth of the Amazon
if I remember it correctly that just
through navigation and the Stars they
were able to calculate where the way was
back to Spain and make a boat seaworthy
enough to bring them home foreign
people like that inspire you your own
Journey like what gives you kind of
strength that um
in these harshes of times and harshes of
conditions you can persevere yeah I mean
you look at the stories of people that
are so you know these stories of people
that have overcome incredible suffering
like that or like you know what
Shackleton did or something like that
and so like when you're you know I've
been you know your tent gets washed away
you go to sleep and the river Rises 20
feet and washes away your tent and you
crawl out and all you have is Machete
and a headlamp literally no bag no food
no nothing and you go wow the next six
days before I reach back to a town is
going to be just pure hell I'm going to
be sleeping on the ground covered in
ants destroyed by mosquitoes and then it
becomes you know am I in any capacity
any percentage as tough and resilient as
the people that I've read about that
have made it through things far worse
than this and and then that's the game
you play what goes through your head
when all you got is the headlamp and the
machete so are you uh thinking at all
like I I've gotten a chance to interact
quite a lot with Elon Musk and he
constantly puts out fires having to run
several companies there's never a kind
of uh
why need deliberation about issues
you're just always
one one step forward how to solve right
this is the situation how do you solve
it or do you also have a kind of
self-motivating
almost egotistical like I'm a bad
[__] I can handle anything
almost like trying to fake it till you
make it kind of thing
there was a little bit of your machete
you know I got a sword
um
there maybe may have been a little bit
of that when I was like you know like 14
15 years old I'd like you know have like
a hunting knife in my dog and I'd go out
into the woods or like the Catskills and
survive for a weekend which my rule was
one match
you know you get one match and you got
to make shelter and then you know I'd
bring like a steak and like make a fire
and stuff and at that point there maybe
was some ego but in the Amazon
you get stripped down so completely that
you
it's like that thing like you know watch
the atheism leave everyone's body when
they think they're about to die it's
like when you
find yourself staring up at the Amazon
at night and you go there is no hope of
getting out of here I mean I was once
lost in a swamp where it took me days to
get out of there and there was there was
moments where I just said this is you
know this is clearly it there's no
there's no ego there there's just hope
you you start you start realizing what
you believe in and
praying that you'll be okay and and then
trying to trying to summon whatever you
know about how to survive and
and that's it and so it's it's actually
again it's kind of it's kind of a
blissful state if you can walk that line
between like Adventure and tragedy and
sort of keep yourself right at that very
very fine line without going over ever
fear of death fear ever fear
um Tara no I don't want to die I wanna I
wanna you know I I love the people in my
life and there's a lot of things I want
to do but every time I've been every
time I've been certain that I'm gonna
die it's been I've been very very calm
very calm and just sort of like okay
well if this is how the movie goes and
this is how it goes almost accepting
yeah
which is which is reassuring